well we're in the middle of Nottingham
in the city center at an impending
cinema called the Broadway and normally
they sell lots of all these show lots of
really nice films lots of arty films
things that you won't find in the
showcase but today they're allowing us
to go on stage to the chemistry goes to
the city life
it's a sort of eclectic mixture of some
of the videos off youtube and perhaps a
couple of live experiments you can see
the Roses bloomed it's got bigger
because it's to protect me from the
elements but be so seeing ourselves on
the big screen is actually quite weird
never been done before it's an unusual
experience and actually quite unnerving
so here our selves on the radio or hear
ourselves to see ourselves on YouTube
but that's a really small screen and you
can turn it off can't turn this one off
so we got up the screen one which is
where we're performing today it's got a
plush environment not like a typical
university lecture theatre but very
flammable I wonder if Martin's face will
be on a poster next to John Malkovich
soon and we have Pete license to kill
either so it's very bright or very
purple hmm very plush very comfortable
hope everyone enjoys themselves
do you want a scientist